i personally
have always been i've not been a huge
believer believer in philanthropy i
believe in impact for profit right
so if you can create a business that is
profitable has a you know makes sense
from a business perspective
but has a positive effect on the world
hell yeah i'll sign up for that any day
of the week right so there's also that
element
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed
stanford leap and birthright excel and
in media partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we welcome ori weiss
founder of team odeon ori is an
experienced founder executive and
investor he founded xl media plc a
london listed performance marketing
company in 2003 led it through its ipo
and ran it until 2019 ori is an investor
in companies such as muse midoriyan
gigantic and more his focus is on strong
founder-led teams with disruptive
technology and sector-specific expertise
holy vice welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today
pretty good how are you thanks for
having me thank you so much for being
here i'm looking forward to talking
about your journey talking about the
gaming space along with a bunch of other
spaces that you are part of
transitioning to the education world you
have such a such a long history in in in
the tech scene and the startup scene
both as an investor and as a founder
you've invested in in some of the most
exciting companies that i that i that i
hear about you know on a daily basis now
uh but but i'm also excited to hear
about who you are and as a person and
what motivates you and how and the
convictions that you've come to uh you
know over the years and where you are
today so only you know take me back a
little bit across your journey and share
with me
a little bit about how you what your
career looked like you know from your
perspective
sure um i'm going to try to make it
quick because it can take me some time
but i'm happy the door's locked so we
won't have any kid running in here which
is usually what happens
so i kind of
i
indirectly stumbled into online gambling
of all industries uh somewhere back in
2002 it seems to be a repeating theme a
lot of people somehow ended up there
miraculously so i actually was uh funny
thing is i was one year after the army
was living in israel kind of looking for
what to do with myself everyone i knew
ended up growing long hair and flying to
india i did not i ended up keeping my
short hair and moving the cypress to
work for an online casino uh funny thing
is that i at the time did not know
anything about either gambling or online
or anything that loosely relates to the
topic but a couple of friends from my
hometown from haifa they launched
launched a company these are uh you know
these are guys that have went on later
on they found a bunch of interesting
things as well and i ended up being
their employee number i don't know five
six something like that uh learning as
we go um spent about a year in cyprus uh
after which my mom pretty much decided
for me i need to go back to israel and
study
because uh that's what you do and if you
don't do that you're in big trouble
uh so i came back to israel made a deal
that i'll kind of keep working as a
freelancer and that was kind of where
excel media what would become web pals
excel media kind of spawned i pretty
much uh what i did was running an
affiliate network and developing some
comparison site seo site stuff like that
for the gaming industry or gambling um
predominantly in europe uh pretty much
was a solo operation for a couple years
but started to scale up pretty fast i
was very very fortunate to just be in
the right place in the right time
you know things really worked 2008 i uh
and i'm kind of skipped five years there
2008 i uh decided to merge with a couple
other guys one of them was my next-door
neighbor and heisman the other the third
one was his buddy from the tank
uh and we decided to merge that was what
would become excel and weapons
and we continued together three guys in
the basement in tel aviv
um again fast forwarding a bit 2012 the
business is making you know
the numbers here uh eight digits profit
per year us
like just everything we we're very
fortunate we worked really hard at it
and i have a lot to talk about it but
that's kind of the high level we sold
the majority share of it to private
equity group uh we stayed on board i was
i was ceo ceo of the top co uh the
holding group since day one since 2003.
uh so we we kept them we kept a pretty
big share in it we listed it in london
in 2014.
um
yeah which is a kind of journey i'm
happy to talk about that it's
you know what was it like for you you
know both as you transition you know as
ceo of this holding company and you're
you're thinking through the ambitions
you know from three guys in a garage
like what was that experience like for
you
well just to be it wasn't a garage it
was a real basement a real basement
yeah not like they go
yeah we had plaster walls you can hear
everything so it was a real basement but
uh look i i have to be honest um
the idea of listing wasn't actually mine
it was the private equity guys
apparently when they bought into the
company they kind of decided were going
to do that they didn't even bother to
tell me
they told me when it said okay uh you're
gonna have to start going to london a
lot i was like why yeah we're listening
like okay sounds like it sounds like an
adventure um do i need to learn anything
oh you'll be fine uh
really i gotta end up like that
incredible yeah pretty much i was very
fortunate that they uh
one of the first uh things they did
after investing was um they brought in a
cfo uh and she apparently was in on the
plan i was not
uh and she's done this before she's very
experienced she's been around and
apparently she didn't appreciate my old
financial system which was to check the
bank account every month after we paid
everyone and see
and see if we have more money than last
month
apparently that's not recognizable
accounting system so
i don't know why it sounds very
reasonable to me i didn't i didn't have
i didn't take any i didn't go through an
mba but to me it makes sense right so uh
yeah
so yeah
so that that kind of started the london
journey and all joking aside london was
a great experience for me um personally
i kind of learned a lot of new things i
spent
five years up to 2019
uh running a list of business which is
very very different than running a
non-listed business
how was it different what was different
for you in that regard
first of all you got to wear a suit
which is a big thing for me i i did not
have many suits around but first of all
you got um it it kind of changes the way
you think about things we can talk about
this for hours but i think that kind of
the big thing is that you're catering
not just to the day-to-day of running a
business and caring for your employees
caring for your clients you have this
other group of
people companies the investors which
actually don't really care so much about
your business or your clients they care
about their bottom line and if they can
report that they profited from what from
investing in you and then you've got all
the supporting staff the supporting team
around them analysts
bankers lawyers
um and it takes up a lot of time as well
so i literally
i literally spent about i don't know a
few days a month in london um wow
running around in taxis meeting
investors um again great great
experience but i i would i would say
that
the public life is not for every company
you really have to there's a set of
criteria that i think really should be
kind of like okay if you if this if this
and this and this is you can checklist
okay do it otherwise
think again
right so
yeah so ran xl until 2019 uh left the
executive role in um in the end of 2019
i'm still on the board i'm still a
shareholder uh still involved not not as
much anymore uh since 2010 i think it is
i i've been investing in a bunch of
businesses in a variety of sector
sectors anything from gaming to um
to sas enterprise software healthcare
a couple of friends of mine actually one
of them uh was on your podcast as well
yeah mutual friends so i'm very
fortunate to invested in him and
i'm gonna name drop ron breitman
gigantic
i then they had they had an ama amazing
some amazing announcements uh recently
and and it sounds like the the company
is going going to amazing places and but
rory tell me a little bit about your
mentality then you're you're coming off
of this experience you're investing
you find yourself
you know very deeply rooted into these
industries that you were very that were
very common to you and i'm gonna fast
forward here today you're not in those
industries anymore you know right now
maybe you'll be back to them one day but
but you're in a little bit of a
different place in education
which you know has a lot a lot of
differences from the things you were
doing before i you know you'll talk also
about the similarities but what made you
make this transition
well it's it's a really good question
and um i would say that first of all
look there's the there's the truth and
then there's the
nicer truth so the truth is after
leaving excel i made an over under bet
with my wife how long i can be idle we
put the betting line at six months i
took the over i was obviously wrong
uh i should have taken the under and
after about three months i kind of
started feeling a bit bored um so
the reason i stumbled upon education is
kind of there's two things one is that
it seems to have always been that one
that got away right because at excel we
we acquired a variety of businesses so
we went into personal finance we went
into social gaming we went into web
utilities we've been we looked into a
bunch of stuff we always we looked at a
couple education business they always
looked super interesting very far from
what we do
but they were the ones that got away
right it either didn't fit financially
or it didn't was at the time or whatever
i kind of started looking back into that
i paid i i had a couple of my investor
banker friends take a look at it do some
research and kind of scope what's going
on and i was very happy to see that
it seems to be an industry that can very
much benefit from comparison and i'll be
happy to explain why plus it's an
industry that doesn't it's not saturated
yet it has
really it's lacking some very good
products and it's such an impactful
feeling i know people use this word
impactful a lot uh but this you know the
being at the crux of you know people
making the decision if to study
something or not what to study will it
impact their career positively
employment these are big things and
right i always thought
something i was spending a lot of time
and this is kind of going through my
mind is that how do i use what i know
and what i've done before for something
that has a super positive impact
and i felt like okay you know i used to
compare slot machines let's be honest i
love gaming i'm still involved in gaming
businesses it doesn't really impact your
life if you're gonna choose one slot
machine or the other i gotta be honest
with myself but then if you start going
up that food chain right okay so
comparing sports books again not super
impactful but much more complex right a
lot more data there going moving on to
credit cards insurance we did that as
well and then like okay those are big
things you know what mortgage you're
gonna take you're gonna carry this
weight for a bunch of years you're gonna
be paying back oh yeah then it's thought
and then
hey
you you you come from the financial
sector you know how that works right so
i would say that then i thought okay
what what's next and for me education
felt like the next step because
especially for americans we target the
u.s right especially for american most
of them
may even extra this is extra emphasize
in grad schools right they will take a
big student loan or this will put they
will commit a bunch of time a couple
year two three four years to a degree
out of some assumption that it will
impact their life positively increase
their employability
make make them make more money um
and they make this decision kind of
finger in the air
and that's something that
for me that's the perfect place for
comparison products there's so much data
out there bureau of labor statistics
opec owneth ipads these are government
government tools that people can't use
because they're super complex if i can
help them if i can give them great
content by industry experts and put
together all this mess into something
they can extrapolate data from
i've done well
and that's right that's where they speak
so for the context tell me a little bit
about team odeon and how you
how you
you know decided that this is the right
product to be built and what has led you
to this conviction because you have
experience thinking through consumer
behavior i think you know building
successful businesses
why you know why did you decide on this
well look first of all i admit um
there's a financial validity that this
business makes sense universities and
opm's which is online program managers
they they're very they're really keen uh
to get
new leads for universities for degree
programs for vocational schools which we
can that's a separate topic but very
similar you know vocational schools
anything from uh you know garage door
technician to a nutritionist right it's
certification courses
so there's definitely a financial kind
of there's a business case there
there's a need um there's a lack of
there are good products in the market
but definitely not enough compared to
the size of the market plus it really
fit it fit me and this is kind of i
admit this sounds a little fluffy but
it kind of fit where i want to be in
life right so in the sense that i
personally
have always been i've not been a huge
believer believer in philanthropy i
believe in impact for profit right
so if you can create a business that is
profitable has a you know makes sense
from a business perspective
but has a positive effect on the world
hell yeah i'll sign up for that any day
of the week right so there's also that
element
right dive with me into the business of
team ardern
the both the impact that you're making
on student decision making when it comes
to their academic studies and
professions as well as then how that
leverages into an impactful profitable
business
sure well look it's we're still early
days so give it a disclaimer very early
we have a lot of things
a lot of things are still kind of in the
you know uh under the hood still right
but the idea here is to combine two
things um expertly written content and
by expertly written content uh everyone
throws that around but here you
google has this thing called ymyl your
money your life when you write about
things that have to do with your money
in your life and education is both
you're under
the scrutiny of the most strictest
magnifying glass they have so you've got
to write it has to be validated by
professors or professionals it has to be
very well thought out system
architecture
okay that's one element another element
is bringing together all this data so
we've spent a lot of time and effort
bring aggregating huge amounts of data
from things like the bureau of labor
statistics from companies like pay scale
that give that measure even even like
kind of regional employment stats or
employment volatility give an example to
make it more down to earth right you're
sitting at home and i don't know
kentucky right and you're a registered
nurse and you think
should i get that master's in science in
nursing okay let's look i'll so what
i'll give this person will be okay uh
statistically people in your area when
they make that when they take this
degree they will increase their
employability by seven percent their
average potential earnings by nineteen
percent it will cost them an average of
twenty seven thousand dollars per year
so here's the kind of do with that what
you want so try to give people tools to
make these decisions maybe just maybe
they'll find out that actually a
bachelor's in healthcare administration
they can get to the same job
and they could do it online as a first
as opposed to brick and mortar is and
actually make more uh
increase their employability more
it's kind of making sense of it all it
just i found it hilarious or strange
that people kind of jump into this oh
yeah my parents went to princeton so i'm
gonna go there right right or yeah
university of central florida it's
really close to my house it's kind of
cheap i'm going to go there okay
is that really how you want to be making
one of the most important decisions
you're ever going to make right
right
like that definitely makes sense
and and and this is astonishing is but
we this is not my gut feeling we did
some research we we surveyed people
a lot of them admitted it's really
finger in the air yeah and that that's
that's to me is very surprising now what
what is the feeling like working on this
versus some previous experiences you
know well how is this different or is it
the same
as as your prior endeavors
look
honestly i love doing what i do because
i enjoy the field of creating you know
creating these comparison products i
admit that
i'm really keen to do education because
it has all those positive effects but on
the day-to-day it's it doesn't feel very
different right right
i plus i have to admit a lot of people
say oh you're fixing your karma and i
admit um when we just started this with
just two of us doing this uh the trello
board was called project karma
i do i have to admit it's james's
name
uh we did change the name because um it
didn't feel right to keep it but uh so
yeah of course
i have absolutely no issues with with
gaming or finance it's an industry like
any other industry and i love it and i'm
all i feel like i'm always gonna be part
of it in some capacity plus so many of
my friends come from there but it feels
i admit it feels better to be in this
because
i really feel that we will get back in a
couple of years i'll get these stories
of people yeah you know what uh using
your product made me to make this
decision as opposed to that decision and
my life is so much better now i'm
waiting for that it's going to be a
while but i'm waiting for that i
i don't get that
i doubt i'll get that from the slot
machine
well maybe if somebody want a lot of
money from one of them you'll get you'll
get a really big phone keycard i've been
doing i did gaming for 18 years i'm
still waiting for that email
i love it or you take me back to your
childhood a little bit you know before
before you were an entrepreneur and
you're all about creating things before
you discovered gaming as an industry
what really what really fascinated you
as a child what sparked your curiosity
well i admit that um
tough question i was really creative and
not creative so i was really like
curious about stuff i tried a bunch of
things
i think the one thing that that kind of
stuck to me was uh i loved um
kind of engagement i i don't know what
i'm saying is correct engagement with
people like my my my age 14 job was not
the typical one i still i sold audio
systems because i love music i love
audio systems and i but it's not about
that i okay i love playing around with
the old turntables that for me was
paradise but i love the fact that i can
speak to people i can understand what
they want i try to fit something for
them i can question i can grill them for
an hour and a half about what music they
like and why and
that's the part of it that i love the
most and i think it kind of
i i really do i dig trying to figure out
how people decide stuff that's that's
i can definitely relate now what what
inspires you today whether it's in
whether it's in your work with education
whether it's you know family or personal
life what what really guides you besides
you know just the day-to-day
well um
yeah the fan having a now i have i have
three three small kids um so that
obviously it changes a lot of
perspectives um
in the sense that you start to think
like okay
what's going to be in 20 years so it's
going to be in 15 years so there's i
think that kind of a little bit ties
into the education part that i'm more
engaged in education now
on a day-to-day basis than i ever was
sure in some sense uh some sometimes
successfully some less uh we we did have
a couple of scenes today but uh i admit
but uh so that's that's definitely
changed i think the fact that i've i've
been surrounded by both you know at home
uh my family obviously gives me a lot of
inspiration to try to improve myself but
i've also been very fortunate to be
surrounded by so many uh
talented motivated and successful people
uh a lot of them originated from the
gaming industry and you know in israel
and gaming a lot of interesting things
spawned out of that
um plus here i live i live here in the
czech republic for 10 years i was
literally after two years here i met
randomly at a birthday party um a guy
that turned out to will is now in the
process of becoming probably
the most interesting check startup ever
and i was very fortunate to meet and
it's a company called news um you know
hotel software stuff like that so
somehow i i'm very fortunate to end up
so that's something i'm super grateful
for that it's something
networking somehow works i don't know
definitely and and you know obviously it
sounds like you know going back to
selling stereos it's all about the
relationship building and it's not just
networking but it's actually
understanding people's needs and it
sounds a
big part of your of the reason for your
success across a different endeavor is
all the webs it's this ability to just
understand why people make decisions and
what guides them and what frustrates
them and how to help them either compare
stereo equipment or com or compare what
to do with their life and i think that
that's a really remarkable ollie what
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
wow i should have prepared for this more
it's a tough one no i love this
continuity
no i really i uh this i'm i've been told
that i'm the worst at giving myself
compliments i don't know if it's going
to come out like a good thing um
i think that's something that's
i think that um
uh i try to be very honest
um so i think honesty would be a word
and honest is not just about just
telling the truth but
but honest to myself yeah um and
unprofessionally on a professional level
i'm i try to be very honest with what i
what i think i can do but more
importantly what i can't do
and i admit
uh and i i there are especially on you
know we talked about running a big
company at peak i ran a company that had
450 people in it and admittedly looking
back
there are people that are better better
than me and the you know this founder
thing can
it took me to a place but i honestly had
to look at myself say okay let's bring
somebody else that does this for a
living right
so that's one word um another word is
maybe i don't know how would you
describe someone that
just wants doesn't mind trying anything
adventurous
adventure i'll take adventurous
i'll i'll call a doer
yeah like i somebody will come up to me
and say hey you want to do this like
okay then like
immediately okay and now let's think
through how to do it
yeah
worst case with my wife do you wanna try
the zip line like okay
she regretted it she didn't think i'm
gonna say okay um
last one okay i'm gonna try for some one
more word um
i think that uh maybe dedicated i try to
be really dedicated to what i do i i i
i don't like doing things half-assed
like uh and that's why i sat on the
fence for a while uh thinking about what
to do yeah not enough maybe not enough i
did lose that over under bed but uh if i
decide if i do this i'm doing it right
yeah i love it and you're gonna add one
more one more mini word it's called a
half 100
yes okay so i think the f word is like i
i don't know how to what word is it but
i like to keep things in proportion and
that's tied into the family part and i
for example perspective
from perspective yeah like sometimes
this is something that i kind of grew
into in the last 20 years i think that i
look at a computer oh my god something's
not working with it's work
it'll be fine we'll fix it you know i i
used to be get a lot more and stressed
about things i think i'm fixing that as
on a daily basis but i i tried home life
balance the biggest cliche in the world
but i i live it so i just came back from
the park like literally half an hour ago
so i love it oh wait thank you very much
this is so enjoyable thank you for your
time and your and your energy and
inspiration and stay safe and stealthy
[Music]